when pfizer first reported the efficacy
of their covit 19 vaccine a staggering
95
many thought that would mark an end to
the pandemic but that hasn't happened
vaccination rates have remained low in
certain parts of the world despite
multiple available vaccines and there's
also been reports of breakthrough cases
where fully vaccinated people get
covered and now recent unpublished data
from israel showed that the pfizer
vaccine was only 40 percent effective at
reducing the risk of symptomatic covet
so if the original trials showed high
efficacy why did a large portion of
people in this israeli study get coveted
here's why those two numbers are so far
apart and why neither of them can tell
the full story
to understand this gap first you need to
understand the difference between
efficacy and effectiveness
vaccine efficacy refers to how well a
vaccine performs under ideal tightly
controlled conditions like clinical
trials for example during trials for
covid19 vaccines were given to people on
a tight schedule it also has to do with
what the researchers were studying here
they were looking at how well vaccines
prevented symptomatic infections in a
limited number of people not whether
they prevented infection altogether or
kept people from being contagious and
with covet 19 it's possible to be
infected and not show symptoms what
determines how efficacious or the the
how well the vaccine works in a trial is
really two things lisa lee has studied
the spread of viruses for 30 years and
has held leadership roles at the cdc
it's how contagious the virus is how
many people an infected person might
might infect if uh with in the absence
of a vaccine and it also depends a lot
on the host that is people how how well
can the vaccine stimulate the right
immune response for people in faisal's
study the company tested about 44 000
people for symptomatic covet 19 and only
170 develop the disease with at least
one symptom and of those just eight had
been vaccinated while 162 had gotten the
placebo this is what added up to that 95
efficacy rate this by the way means that
in a vaccinated population 95 fewer
people will contract the disease when
they come in contact with the virus
not that each individual is 95 immune
but that efficacy rate was calculated
during a specific time and under a
specific set of circumstances
many people were staying at home
avoiding large gatherings wearing masks
and the virus hadn't mutated as much
vaccine effectiveness on the other hand
is how a vaccine works in the real world
outside of clinical settings where it's
harder to control variables that were
constant in a study like when people get
their vaccines we know the real world is
kind of messy not everybody gets their
vaccines at the exact interval not
everybody has the same kind of immune
system and behavior is changing too in
many places businesses are open and
large gatherings are happening again
this is part of why efficacy numbers and
trials are often higher than the
effectiveness we see in the real world
and what makes us all the more
complicated is that the virus itself is
still evolving the delta variant which
has become dominant in multiple
countries is more transmissible than
earlier strains of the virus which means
that more people will come in contact
with it it became dominant months after
the vaccines had been authorized and
millions of doses had been distributed
that means our current shots were
designed for an earlier version of the
coronavirus and don't work as well
against delta this is part of why we're
hearing more about breakthrough cases
u.s states counted over 190 000
breakthrough cases between january 1st
and early august this year that's among
millions who are already vaccinated and
remember that israeli study data was
collected for it in june and july when
delta was dominant there health
officials saw breakthrough cases were
more likely among people who had gotten
the vaccine early on in january or
february this is partly because
antibodies which the body produces after
the vaccine to protect itself against
the virus naturally decrease over time
that along with the unknowns about
variants is a big reason why the biden
administration announced new vaccine
recommendations we are announcing our
plan to stay ahead of this virus by
being prepared to offer covid19 booster
shots to fully vaccinated adults 18
years and older what we want to do is
make sure that we keep that immunity
high enough so when it starts to wane we
want to make sure that people are able
to get that third shot that should
increase the chances that the vaccines
prevent severe illness that could then
lead to hospitalization and death
still there's some debate among public
health experts as to whether booster
shots are needed right now that's
because antibodies are not the body's
only defense against the virus there are
also certain immune cells that prepare
the body to fight off pathogens and
those may not be waning and while
breakthrough cases continue to occur
experts say that these cases are usually
mild and don't result in severe illness
let's go back to that israeli data that
showed that the pfizer vaccine is now
only 40 percent effective against
symptomatic covet well that same study
showed that the vaccine had a 91
effectiveness against hospitalization
and death the vaccine really what it
does is help us slow the speeding car
and it helps us to reduce transmission
and that is what's going to get us out
of this pandemic in addition to vaccines
experts also recommend preventive
measures like mask wearing and social
distancing to keep the virus from
spreading and mutating further
[Music]